meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
liebe
freundinnen und freunde
das ist heute ein ganz besonderer
wahlabend
zum ersten mal
seit 16 jahren
hat angela merkel nicht mehr als
bundeskanzlerin
kandidiert das waren 16 gute jahre für
deutschland und deshalb gilt mein erster
dank der bundeskanzlerin angela merkel
für ihre arbeit
aber
und zwar klar
und zwar klar ohne amtsbonus wird dass
ein offener ein achter ein enger
wahlkampf und so ist es auch gekommen
es ist ein kopf an kopf rennen dieser
wahlabend ist eine ausnahme situation
wir haben derzeit noch keine gesicherten
endergebnisse keine gesicherten zahlen
aber wir können jetzt schon sagen mit
dem ergebnis können wir nicht zufrieden
sein
und trotzdem eine ausgang der wahl ist
noch völlig unklar es wird ein langer
abend und in jedem fall stellt das
wahlergebnis
deutschland die union
alle demokratischen parteien vor große
herausforderungen
wir müssen die weichen stellen für die
zwanziger jahre
das kann keine partei alleine und
deshalb bedarf es jetzt einer großen
kraftanstrengung aller demokratinnen und
demokraten
wir müssen gegensätze überwinden und
deutschland zusammen halten es wird
erstmals
aller voraussicht nach eine
bundesregierung mit drei
bündnispartnern geben können und wir als
union haben von unseren wählerinnen und
wählern einen klaren auftrag erhalten
eine stimme für die union ist eine
stimme gegen eine links geführte
bundesregierung
und deshalb
deshalb werden wir alles daran setzen
eine bundesregierung unter führung der
union zu bilden denn deutschland
deutschland
deutschland braucht jetzt eine zukunfts
koalition die unser land modernisiert
deutschland braucht eine koalition für
mehr nachhaltigkeit in jeder hinsicht
beim klimaschutz und bei den finanzen
wir tragen verantwortung für die
künftigen generationen
für unsere kinder und enkel und dieser
verantwortung müssen wir stärker gerecht
werden als bisher gerade beim
klimaschutz wir brauchen eine koalition
die unser land schneller macht und
digitalisiert dass unser land von
fesseln befreit und bei planen und
genehmigungsverfahren mehr tempo
ermöglicht wir brauchen eine koalition
die für weltoffenheit steht und für
marktwirtschaftliche lösungen eine
koalition die europa stärkt und die
gemeinsam mit den gleichgesinnten
demokratien in der welt die
herausforderungen der zukunft
gestaltet eine koalition die einen
beitrag leistet für eine bessere welt
dafür werde ich
dafür
dafür werde ich ab jetzt arbeiten
gemeinsam mit markus söder gemeinsam mit
unserem gesamten team und in dieser
koalition
muss sich jeder partner wiederfinden
muss sich jeder mit seinen schwerpunkten
wiederfinden es muss eine koalition
werden die das land zusammenhält und in
der jeder
auch das umsetzen kann was er seinen
wählern versprochen hat ich gratuliere
allen wettbewerbern zu ihren
wahlergebnissen und danke für einen
wahlkampf der fast immer fair war vor
allem danke ich euch alle bin bei
kämpferinnen und wahlkämpfern von cdu
und csu von nord und süd von ost bis
west
das war ein gelungener and spruch das
war eine große aufholjagd ihr habt
großes geleistet die ab nie aufgegeben
und das ist auch mein antrieb das ist
unser antrieb für die zukunft
der wahlkampf
der wahlkampf ist vorbei jetzt geht es
um 1 eine stabile koalition für ein
starkes und modernes deutschland und
bundeskanzler wird der dem es gelingt
gegensätze zu verbinden und ein gutes
gemeinsames programm für die nächsten
vier jahre zu entwickeln
ein bundeskanzler
bundeskanzler wird der der im deutschen
bundestag genau diese gegensätze
überwindet eine mehrheit findet der
jetzt gewählten abgeordneten überall
inland und es muss ein bundeskanzler
sein für alle die in deutschland leben
das ist die aufgabenstellung die vor uns
liegt es wird viele intensive gespräche
mit den politischen wettbewerberinnen
und wettbewerbern in den nächsten tagen
geben
dieser bundeskanzler muss ein projekt
entwickeln das länger trägt als nur die
nächsten wochen eine wichtige
wahlperiode liegt vor uns zu dieser
aufgabe bin ich bereit
[Applaus]